another form of the larger category of
vicar or remembrance is another common
Sufi practice called Sama which
literally means listening or audition
this is a practice that involves
listening to recited poetry or music as
a spiritual observance it's been made
famous by its more elaborate examples
such as the whirling dervishes of the
meblovy order
IBN faded seems to have been especially
fond of sama there are many stories of
how he would participate in such musical
assemblies and fall into ecstatic States
as a result in one if not farted
spontaneously enters a state of watched
as he simply hears the singing of some
people walking by him in the marketplace
quote a group of guards passed by IBN
faded while they were beating clappers
and singing
upon hearing these verses shouted out
and danced in the marketplace
this attracted a large crowd of people
many of whom fell to the ground in
ecstasy as the guards continue to sing